عندما يلتقي الاصدقاء فيما بينهم بولايه
مشيغن هذه الايام يطغى موضوع خيار بايدن
ام لا في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله مع
نهايه العام الله عز وجل ها سنن يقول
الناخبون العرب انهم مصدومون من مواقف
الرئيس بايدن منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه
وغاضب من دعمه بشكل مطلق حسب قولهم
لاسرائيل وعدم التفاته الى ضحايا غزه لهذه
الاسباب يقولون انهم س صوتهم الانتخابيه
لطرف ثالث بعيدا عن الحزب الديمقراطي حكيت
مع ناس قرابين بمش بهيوستن تكساس حتى
العرب هناك نفس الشي كلهم واقفين وقفه
وحده انه ضد بايدن للانتخابات
الجايه الشيء الوحيد الذي لا اتفق بشانه
هو اننا نناديه هنا بجول الاباده او جول
جزار هل مستحيل مستحيل انا وا اي واحد حدي
يصوت لبايدن حتى لو رج لعنا اليوم وغير
رايه ما في له صوت ما في له صوت كان لموقف
الرئيس بايدن الداعم لاسرائيل في حربها
على غزه اثر مباشر على الناخبين العرب
والمسلمين بولايه مشيغن فتد نت شعبيته في
اوسطهم هم الذين كانوا ساهموا بشكل واضح
في فوزه بولايه مشيغن عام 2020 عندما واجه
المرشح ترامب
انذاك ومنذ بدايه حرب غزه الى يومنا وامام
عدم مطالبه الرئيس بايدن بوقف اطلاق النار
في غزه بشكل صريح حسب الناخبين العرب
تضاعف غضبهم من البيت الابيض وشاركوا
بفعاليه في المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه بولايه
مشجن استطلاعات رائين للمعهد العربي
الامريكي بواشنطن ذكرت ان شعبيه بايدن
تراجعت بالفعل وبشكل ملحوظ منذ بدايه
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وان غضب
الناخبين العرب دفعهم الان الى القيام
بحملات الكترونيه تدعو صراحه الى التخلي
عن حمله بايدن الانتخابيه والدخول في
تحالف جديده الجيل الصاعد يعني الفتي يعني
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الناخب
الصغير يعني بالعمر اللي هو بين ال 18 35
هو يعني 62% او 67% حسب الاحصاءات معنا
نحن بده وقف اطلاق النار وهذ توقيف
المجازر لانه نحنا مش بس لوحدنا ننا عننا
حلفاء في الجاليه السوداء في الجاليه
الاسبانيه مع استمرار الحرب والى اجل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه اختار
الناخبون العرب والمسلمون المشاركه في
عشرات الاحتجاجات الاسبوعيه في الولايات
المتحده الى جانب باقي الامريكيين
للمطالبه بوقف اطلاق النار ويوم التصويت
قد يعاقبون الرئيس بايدن في صنادق
الاقتراع يتفادى البيت الابيض الرد على
الناخبين المسلمين بشكل مباشر ولكن الرئيس
بايدن اكد في تصريحات قبل يومين انه هو
المرشح الذي يحمي حقوق الاقليات عكس
منافسي ترامب الذي يتوعد الان مناصري حماس
كما
بالتردي والترحيل ناصر حسين الجزيره
ديربورن
مشجن